Salut ! Aujourd'hui j'ai une vidéo avec une invitée.
On va discuter de quelque chose d'assez passionant.
Mais je n'ai pas mon pied de caméra, je ne l'ai pas pris. Heureusement, j'ai toujours un pied de caméra de secours...
C'est Raj !
Au tout début de l'année quand je me suis lancé sur YouTube, la première personne qui est venue me voir en spectacle et qui était un peu du YouTube game et qui m'a contacté c'est Laetitia.
De la chaine Le Corps La Maison l'Esprit.
-Coucou !
-Voilà, c'est une meuf minimaliste donc elle économise ces mots.
On va y revenir...
[rires]
-J'ai meme pas fait exprès ! [rires]
-Alors, en quelques mots c'est quoi la définition pour toi du minimalisme ?
-En fait il y a plusieurs définitions du minimalisme mais globalement quand tu es minimaliste tu essayes de vivre avec le moins de choses possible,
et de simplifier au maximum ta vie.
Voilà.
-Donc le moins de choses matérielles.
-Le moins de choses matérielles. Alors souvent le minimalisme on le voit d'un point de vue matériel.
-Ouais.
-Mon minimalisme à moi il est plus au niveau de ma manière de vivre globalement et au niveau de ma manière de penser, de ma manière de réflechir les choses.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe pour une meuf,
par exemple à partir du moment où elle n'achète plus de vêtements ?
-Eh beh écoute...
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe dans ta tete ?
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe dans ma tête ?
-Et bien en fait c'est hyper interessant parce que si tu veux, quand tu es une fille, t'es dans la rue et tu es tout le temps sollicitiée.
En permanence.
-Ouais.
-Tu vois, il y a des boutiques, il y a des... on t'incite à acheter, quand tu es dans un magasin tu regardes tout le temps les choses...
Tu sais t'as cet espèce de truc de te dire "je vais peut être trouver quelque chose..."
Et ça prend énormément d'énergie !
Et en fait moi un jour j'ai décidé de ne plus rien acheter, je me suis dis: "pour cette saison je n'achète pas, je garde ce que j'ai !"
Et puis j'ai fait une saison, j'ai fait une autre saison, j'ai fait une autre saison... et là maintenant j'en suis à genre...6, bientôt 7 ans.
Tu vois sans rien acheter.
Et en fait, ça libère complètement mon esprit et ça me fait économiser énormément d'énergie au quotidien.
Moi quand je suis dans la rue, il n'y a rien qui attire mon attention, il n'y a aucun magasin qui attire mon attention.
Je n'ai pas envie d'acheter, je n'ai plus envie d'entrer dans un magasin.
Tu vois quand je suis dans un magasin, ça me prends trop d'énergie, je ne peux plus !
-Et quand tu dis que ça te fait économiser de l'énergie, c'est physique mais c'est aussi mental du coup ?
-Exactement.
En fait je me suis rendue compte que tu vois, au quotidien on fait des choix, tout le temps.
-Ouais.
-On est sollicité en permanence.
Et le fait de limiter mes choix au minimum, ça me permet de garder mon énergie pour les choix qui sont importants.
Tu vois ?
Par exemple le matin devant mon armoire, moi je ne me pose pas 15 000 questions...
Si j'achetai pleins de vêtements, si j'avais pleins de vêtements, je réfléchirai à comment je m'habille, il faut que mon haut soit assorti avec mon pantalon...
J'étais comme ça avant !
Que mon pantalon soit assorti avec mes chaussures, qui'il soit assorti avec mon maquillage...
Qu'il soit assorti avec mon sac...
Tout ça tout ça...
Bon, maintenant, dans mon armoire je n'ai pas beaucoup d'habits, je prends ce que j'ai, je le porte.
Généralement c'est très simple.
-Et est-ce que à l'inverse tu prends les choses au premier degré parce que tu as décidé que tu n'étais pas concernée par ce mode communication là ?
-C'est-à-dire ? Pardon.
-Avec moi, si j'essaye de te faire un sous entendu par exemple,
-Ouais.
tu sais en mode viens faire une vidéo, alors qu'en fait c'est juste pour te voir, me rapprocher de toi, tu vois...
-Ouais ! Je savais, je savais ! [rires]
-Est-ce que... Est-ce que toi tu vas analyser les doubles langages en disant: "attends il me dis ça parce qu'en fait il veut ça..."
-Non parce que je suis un petit peu débile aussi.
-Eh ouais...
[rires]
Je pense que...
-Non, je sais pas...
-Il y avait déjà des comités, tu sais
[rires]
On le soutient.
-Oui mais on le savait déjà, on le savait déjà.
[rires]
-Purée elle est intéressante ta question mais je ne sais pas comment y répondre.
Hum...
Je crois qu'en fait je ne me pose pas énormément de questions. Tu vois je prends le truc comme ça vient.
-Hum.
-Je crois que je ne me trompe pas souvent sur les gens et sur l'intention, mais je ne vais pas réfléchir 10 000 ans à qu'est-ce que veut la personne, est-ce qu'il m'a dit ça parce que ça, parce que ça...
Même dans mon rapport à l'autre quand il est inversé il faut que ce soit simple.
Par contre les gens qui ne sont pas simples, j'ai tendance effectivement à les éloigner de moi.
-Parce que par exemple dans le projet Juncker,
-Ouais ?
si vous n'avez pas vu toutes ces vidéos, si vous les avez vu mais vous ne les avez peut être pas reconnu Laetitia,
c'est elle qui a parlé au président de la commission européenne dans le projet Junker etc.
-Hum.
J'ai le droit d'en parler ?
-Ah oui oui.
-Ils ont arreté de te poursuivre ?
[rires]
-Parce qu'il y a la NSA qui l'a suivait...
Forcément il a fallu que tu détectes en fait quel était le désir de YouTube, de la commission européenne et tout ça pour pouvoir réagir contre, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
-Oui.
-Ca démontre une forme d'intelligence. Pour une fois. Un hasard...
[rires]
-Alors on va dire que c'était une chance et un hasard.
J'étais très bien entourée.
-Ouais.
-Je me suis retrouvée dans des situations, c'est pile cet exemple là...
où on était en face d'un mec qui était un lobbyiste, Raj et moi,
qui nous disait quelque chose et à la fin de la conversation, moi j'avais compris un truc, Raj avait compris un autre truc,
et heu... on a du regarder les images plusieurs fois pour s'en rendre compte que j'avais tort.
[rires]
Et que j'étais vraiment c** en fait !
Mais non, j'étais très bien entourée.
-Et du coup le minimalisme ça va aussi avec... la cosméto, l'hygiène, etc ?
[rires]
-Eh oui !
On va faire un test avant qu'il dise la suite !
Attends ! [rires]
Sens moi.
-Ouais, ouais...
Ah, j'avais déjà...
[rires]
-Il dit ça en fait je sais qu'il veut se moquer de moi,
-Non !
mais il dit ça parce que je me lave à l'eau.
-Non, c'est pour le titre de la vidéo.
[rires]
-Ah c'est pour ton titre putaclic !
Je sais que t'es un mec putaclic, on le sait tous !
Toi et moi on sait ce qu'il fait sur sa chaine !
Bref ! Je me lave à l'eau depuis un an.
Et d'ailleurs j'ai sorti une vidéo sur le sujet où je fais mon bilan et effectivement c'est une forme de minimalisme.
-Juste pour dire je vais la mettre en lien dans la descripition de cette vidéo.
-Ouais !
Et en fait le truc c'est qu'avant j'utilisais des gels douche des trucs comme ça, j'ai commencé à rentrer dans le délire bio écolo machin...
donc j'ai supprimé le plastique, ce qui créé des déchets surtout ce qui est chimique.
Et j'ai eu la question de: est-ce que je me lave avec du savon ou pas, parce que ça aurait pu être une réponse intéressante.
Mais quand j'achetais mon savon je devais vérifier au niveau de l'étiquetage si c'était un vrai bon savon et compagnie...
Ça m'a très vite saoulée, moi dès que c'est un petit peu compliqué ça me fatigue.
J'avais la solution de me laver à l'eau, ça avait l'air cool, j'ai tenté, pendant 3 mois je ne l'ai pas dis à mon mari donc je voulais savoir si je puais ou pas.
Je ne pue pas !
Je ne pue pas.
Il ne s'en est pas rendu compte, donc j'ai fait ça pendant un an.
Et maintenant je continue !
Et c'est trop bien !
Parce qu'en fait dans tous les aspects de ta vie, tu peux simplifier les choses.
On a tendance à tout le temps compliquer.
Merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo !
Merci à notre pote Raj qui fait le pied de caméra.
Et merci encore une fois à toi Laeti.
N'hésitez pas à visiter sa chaine, il y a les liens qu'il faut dans la description.
Vous pouvez aussi mettre un pouce en l'air si ça vous a plu.
Et puis le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre !
-Et c'est bientot fini !
-Oui... le Mental Vlog ! Pas la chaine !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]